i do have to say happy belated birthday
thanks
it's been a couple weeks but you did get
yourself
quite the treat you got yourself the
iron man suit
and then recently you added the iron man
car it's a mclaren you have iron man's
heart look at this you come over here
close this big ass door look how sick
the whole thing
lights up well no i didn't i did the the
car was borrowed yeah i bought an iron
machine really just went from here to
here for me
no no because you left out the best part
is i um i i got the suit and then i got
a tweet from robert downey jr
um saying happy birthday which was like
i don't
i mean that's like that's the craziest
thing because he's an actual superhero
like in real life and and in the movies
so it's like a really cool thing to be
able to get that and that was super
exciting
and it made the suit so so worth it um
so you wear the suit regularly yeah
every morning i go for a jog in it
so that you go for your hike in the and
i go for a hike and sometimes i
i think to myself if i jump off this
side of the cliff will i be able to fly
home
no i i don't i don't get back in the
suit ever because it's so
it's so it's so tough to get into like i
have to there's
three people that have to help me and i
have to like jump off my bed like
into the legs of the suit because it
like i don't know it's it's like molded
and shaped to me
it took me like four months to get they
had to um like i had to get all my
measurements for it
and then like i even forgot about it
when it came in it just came in like a
ginormous crate
and i was like i know what that is have
you ever met robert downey jr or was
just the tweet yeah yeah
yeah i met him at the teen choice awards
and and his trailer was right across
from mine
and i was uh hosting the award show um
for that moment and i was like well if
there's anything i can do
it's me them this is my moment like i'm
hosting the show like this is my one
perk i can meet the talent here
yeah and he yeah and he walked by my
dressing room because he was going to
his not because he was like
he wasn't trying to find you walked by
he looked into my window david are you
in there no and i came
out and i was like hi and like my voice
cracked it was brutal
yeah i told him what a big fan i was and
i was like i'm sorry i haven't i
literally said this i was like i'm sorry
i have nothing else to say i'm so
nervous and then i went back to my
trailer
i've never been like that uncomfortable
when did you when did your love for rdj
and
also iron man start the moment i think
it was
i mean it was the first iron man when
he's doing the interview at the end of
the movie
and he has to stick to these note cards
during his interview
and he can't obviously can't tell
anybody that he's iron man but he
but he disregards the note cards and he
and he says i am iron man and the music
kicks in
i am iron man
that moment is like that moment is like
change the thinking in my head like i
remember when i saw it
like and where i was and like i was just
like whoa like i got chills and i was
like that was the coolest
thing ever and then yeah and i just been
the biggest fan
is that the the craziest purchase that
you've ever made
the craziest purchase yeah oh no
i see that on your face no no i i
i bought some really really goofy things
um
i mean it's a little strange because you
only kind of use it once
but like i bought cars here and there
and then i you know
house um i'm looking for
those are necessities yeah yeah those
are
yeah you're right okay so maybe it is
it's definitely a little strange it's
definitely the one where people go
why did he do that so it's definitely
it's definitely one of those
and then finally why should people tune
in and watch
dodgeball thunderdome mcgivern i mean
first of all it's just it's
it's just easy to watch people are
falling um people are swimming in swamps
mud and on top of that um people can win
when they're watching
you could win five thousand dollars
every episode there's a code that pops
up at the bottom of the screen
and you put that code into uh into the
discovery website and you're entered for
a chance to win 5000. it's literally
that easy so every episode watch
find the code um and and keep me
employed so just go and watch that's why
you should watch so i have a job